in the last video we saw how a bank
would account for
fractional reserve lending on its
balance sheet and we did it with kind of
the conceptual understanding that we've
been talking about fractional reserve
lending the entire time someone deposits
100 million in reserves and 90 million
of it gets lent out and of course the
offsetting liability is that that person
could come at any time and demand their
money back and when that 90 million of
currency is lent out the asset that's
gotten in exchange for it is 90 million
worth of ious now what i want to do in
this video is to clarify that this is
conceptually a good way of thinking
about fractional reserve lending but
what the bank can actually do is
slightly different than this they can
actually create they can actually create
the they can expand both the asset and
the liability side of their account with
just 10 million of reserves to make this
exact same thing happen and one thing i
do want to clarify these videos they are
not an attempt to either justify
fractional reserve lending or in some
way indict fractional reserve lending
it's really just to show how it is
accounted for you can take that debate
on your own side whether you think it's
worth doing or not fractional reserve
lending so let's take the same example
but now let's take an example where so
we're going to start the same way that
we started in the previous video where i
go by i go buy 10 million dollars worth
of assets which are essentially the
building and things for my bank the
buildings the atms the computer systems
all of that and i didn't take a loan to
do it let's just say i had that money so
once again i am the owner of this bank
and so i get 10
so i have all of the assets are owned by
me so my owner's equity is 10 million
dollars
is 10 million dollars
and now in this example instead of
getting a hundred million dollars of
deposits like we saw in the last one
let's say that person a shows up and
gives us 10 million dollars of deposits
so they come and they deposit 10 million
dollars of currency
so 10 million dollars of federal reserve
notes so right over there 10 million and
then they
they can demand person a has a right to
demand their 10 million dollars so this
person let's call them person b person b
is 1 10 as wealthy as person a so this
is person b
i'll just call it b's
b's checking
b's checking account
now this is going to seem very
unintuitive what i'm about to do so
because a bank only has to keep of the
amount of checkable deposits they have
only 10 percent of that has to be in
reserves and we saw that over here
instead of just only being able to lend
this money over here the bank could keep
these reserves but then automatically
expand their checking their checkable
deposits so let's say i go to this bank
right over here
and i want a 50 million dollar loan so
they're going to say okay is he good for
the 50 million loan is he's going to put
it to good use is he likely to pay let's
say they do decide that sal is good for
the money so what they can do
what they can do they're gonna lend me
the money but they're not they don't
they don't even have fifty dollars of
currency to lend the money with what
they will do is that they will create a
50 million dollar checking account for
me so they will create a 50 million
dollar checking account so sals
sals 50 sales checking
sal's checking account and obviously the
bank isn't in the business of just
giving away money what they will do is
they'll have an offsetting asset that
they will get from sal which is an iou
from sal so let me write it this way so
loan to sal would be an asset because in
the future sal is going to pay the bank
so we could call this loan to sal or we
could call this iou
iou from sal
and let's say that bill comes along i'm
just making up names let's say bill
comes along and he wants to borrow
another let's say 40 million dollars and
the bank determines that it's a good
it's a good investment and so let me
actually this is a this is just to make
clear this was a 50 million this is a 50
million ioe iu from sal and this is i
have 50 million
worth of i guess i can write checks up
to 50 million to go buy you know this
was a 50 million loan so i can write
checks against this now to go and build
my business or whatever or i could even
take those checks
and i could cash them out and of course
the bank has to make sure it has enough
reserves it wouldn't want me to show up
and try to cash out more than 10 million
dollars if i if that started to happen
they would have to go and borrow
reserves from either another bank or as
a last resort from a central bank but
let's just continue this just to show
that we can actually end up having
identical identical balance sheets so
let's say another
another businessman let's call him bill
comes along and let's say that he wants
to borrow 40 million dollars so the
exact same thing the bank decides to do
it so what they will do is they will
lend bill 40 million dollars but once
again they don't have that mentioned
reserves they will essentially create a
checking account for bill
so bills
bills 40 million
40 million dollar checking account
and of course they don't want to just
hand them the money there's going to be
an offsetting asset they get from bill
which is essentially a 40 million 40
million
iou iou
from
from bill
and now you might say well can't the
bank just keep doing this just creating
keep getting more and more ius keep kind
of creating money because these checking
accounts really are money your money
creating these people can now write
checks against the bank's ability to
cash those checks and the answer is
what's limiting this bank right over
here is the reserve requirements the
bank can only the ratio of checkable
deposits to reserves can only be ten to
one or reserves have to be at least and
this varies from country to country and
this can change depending on the
policies of the federal reserve and
that's one way that they have of
controlling money although that's not
the most typical way they have a reserve
requirement here you have a 10 so 10
of checkable deposits and this is true
for large banks in the us have to be
held as reserves there has to be
reserves for
reserves
for 10 percent of
10 of checkable deposits and that's what
essentially keeps these banks from doing
this forever so now this bank is all
tapped out it's limited by the amount of
loans it has by its reserves and i know
it looks a little bit it looks a little
bit suspect that they were able to
essentially create these checking
accounts out out of scratch and and only
have they're essentially they're telling
people look there's a hundred million
that you can have on demand now to do
whatever you need when they only have 10
million in reserves to back that up the
rest of their assets are ious from
people but this is exactly what's
happening with the other conceptual
version that gets the more traditional
conceptual res
more
traditional conceptual understanding of
fractional reserve lending you're
telling someone that they have 100
million on demand but you're loaning 90
million of it out what they really have
truly in the vault is 10 million dollars
so these two things these two things are
actually functionally these two things
are completely equivalent and if you
have a problem with one of these if you
feel like just money is being created by
the bank that's actually happening in
both cases and in that case you would
actually have be having a trouble with
with fractional reserve lending not not
just this idea right over here